After Disney fired James Gunn as the director
of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3 in July
2018, the threequel film meant to close out
the franchise got pushed onto rocky ground
and placed on a temporary production halt.
Now, reports have surfaced that suggest Guardians
Vol. 3 might get completely booted out of
its spot on Marvel's release schedule, with
what's being described as a "surprise MCU
film" replacing it.
So, what is this unforeseen Marvel Cinematic
Universe installment?
According to the folks at ScreenGeek, the
answer is...kind of strange.
"Stop."
ScreenGeek recently picked up on an exclusive
report that The Daily Mirror published in
mid-August, one that claimed Benedict Cumberbatch
is poised to earn just under $10 million to
top-line a sequel to his 2016 solo superhero
movie Doctor Strange.
The Daily Mirror further alleged that Marvel
will get Doctor Strange 2 behind cameras in
spring 2019, estimating that filming "could
take as long as six months."
Taking this nugget of information, ScreenGeek
explored what it could mean for the MCU as
a whole, coming up with the idea that Doctor
Strange 2 could take precedence over Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3 on Marvel's to-do list.
The outlet pointed to Cumberbatch's reported
$6.6 million salary increase as a primary
piece of evidence supporting that idea, and
looked to a mysterious message Doctor Strange
director Scott Derrickson posted to Instagram
as additional corroboration.
In July, shortly after Gunn's firing, Derrickson
shared an image of Doctor Strange from the
Marvel comic books with the caption:
"'Not my will, but thine be done…'
See you in September."
Many fans took this to mean that Marvel had
gotten to work on Doctor Strange 2, and that
the studio would be making a major announcement
regarding the sequel pic sometime in September.
It would be easy to shut down the idea that
Doctor Strange 2 is really in the works considering
Disney and Marvel haven't made an official
announcement about it or given it a release
date.
However, Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige
did actually reveal that a Doctor Strange
sequel is happening.
He told CinemaBlend earlier this year:
"[Doctor] Strange, you know, whenever we do
another Strange one, which we will do, it
will be a number of years from the first Strange,
and yet he's a very big part of [Avengers:]
Infinity War.
So it is just a good problem to have when
you have too many beloved characters that
people want to see more of."
Popular speculation is that Marvel will release
Doctor Strange 2 sometime in 2020 - the same
year Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3 was meant
to debut, at least according to Gunn.
If The Daily Mirror's report is to be believed,
a 2020 premiere for Doctor Strange 2 would
certainly make sense.
An early 2019 filming start date and a mid-2019
end date would give the filmmaking team at
least a year to piece together the movie,
add in what's bound to be a ton of CGI, and
smooth out any kinks.
The real question here, though, is whether
Doctor Strange 2 will actually replace Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3 on Marvel's movie docket.
Marvel never formally dated Guardians Vol.
3, but the studio does have three dates in
2020 reserved for MCU entries: May 1st, July
31st, and November 6th.
The third Guardians movie could have occupied
any one of those spots, and if Marvel really
does plan to launch Doctor Strange that year,
the Sorcerer's sequel may have knocked Guardians
3 out of one of those dates.
Unfortunately, it's all a big bundle of conjecture
for now, but with Derrickson teasing what
could be a huge announcement in September,
it appears that things are really heating
up for the Doctor Strange sequel.
For the time being, however, Marvel fans can
still look forward to catching Captain Marvel,
Avengers 4 and Spider-Man: Far From Home in
2019.